on may 23 2017
a group of around 200 armed men who
pledged allegiance to the armed group
isil
laid siege to the city of marawi in the
southern philippines
and raised the group's black flag over
several government facilities
thousands of civilians were held hostage
and the philippine military launched an
all-out offensive
to free them five months later
the battle was over but marawi was by
now the most devastated city in the
philippines
since world war ii more than a thousand
people were killed
and millions more displaced
president rodrigo duterte promised the
city would be rebuilt
but four years later many maranaos feel
they have been forgotten
[Music]
there is still a search for missing
loved ones and hundreds of bodies buried
in haste
during the conflict remain unidentified
reconstruction efforts in the city are
slow and thousands of people
are still unable to go home inside
gov a non-governmental organization
focused
on mapping marawi's recovery says it is
hard to fully assess the real costs
of the five months of war you had a 250
hectare
urban uh city you know destroyed it's
just like bakati cbd being bombed to
bits
it's not acceptable and that the
priority has to be helping people go
home
security remains a problem too according
to international alert
which monitors conflicts clan wars are
making a comeback
illicit drug use is rising too while
armed groups continue to recruit young
men even in areas where conflicts
have ended we just interviewed about
two recent surrenders they've actually
said that you know
it's being tapped of course by the
extremist groups they're using the
the delay in the reconstruction of
marawi
as a rallying point to try and stoke
frustrations of people
the task force formed by the duterte
administration admits
there have been challenges including the
kobit 19 pandemic
and the economic recession which have
caused delays to the reconstruction of
marawi
it says it remains committed to getting
marawi back
to a thriving and vibrant city
but critics say so much time has been
squandered by a government
that was once given sweeping powers to
implement reforms
across the llano province while
survivors say
there is nothing to commemorate because
another year equates to another layer of
hardship
for most of them who are left to fend
for themselves
jamella lindogan al jazeera manila